bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors l'analyse du
téléphone un de steve a permis de situer
le moment de sa chute dans la loire à
4h33 c'est à dire pendant l'intervention
policière
comment accueillez vous cette nouvelle
aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui je pense
que c'est pas en tout cas pour moi ça
constitue un élément fondamental un
tournant peut-être de l'enquêté nous ses
amis on se doutait je pense qu'on s'en
douter tout ça mais c'est important de
savoir que ce téléphone était toujours
actif au moment où les forces de l'ordre
sont intervenues et qui s'est éteint
pendant l'intervention des forces de
l'ordre
contrairement à ce qu'a pu dire le
rapport de l'igpn en juillet 2019
ce rapport qui a été repris ensuite par
le premise qui est que sauf que ça a
l'air un temps les yeux ont quand même
dit à la france et à la famille de steve
qu'en aucun cas un lien ne pouvait être
fait entre l'intervention de la police
et la disparition de style alors le
procureur de la république 1 de rennes a
provoqué plusieurs personnes dont deux
policiers
deux choses ça va peut-être premièrement
permettre de faire la lumière sur ce qui
s'est passé le soir où steve et est
décédé et puis deuxièmement ça peut
peut-être conduire à de potentiels mise
en examen oui oui moi j'ai le sentiment
que quand fin ça bouge après je sais pas
ce que ça va donner j'ai fait confiance
à justice avoir ça ça bouge après deux
ans et l'excès convocation ait lieu
c'est une avancée importante je pense
pour ses amis pour sa famille
justement vous êtes en contact avec sa
famille vous avez des nouvelles je veux
pas aborder ce sujet là d'accord non
c'était pour savoir comment ils sont et
comment eux aussi avaient accueilli
cette nouvelle
là je peux pas parler pour le moment ses
preuves
très bien merci anne claire gérin en
tout cas merci à vous d'avoir et ton
direct avec nous sur rt français d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes une amie de steve merci à vous